when you start learning a new language
have you ever done the following you've
gone to the local bookstore and bought a
bunch of language learning materials you
have started surfing on the internet
trying to find every sort of language
platform you could find you have
downloaded a bunch of apps on your phone
well don't do that ever again hi my name
is Luca from Luke Alan Perez comm and
today we're going to talk about how to
choose that one language learning
resource that is going to make all the
difference
have you ever heard of the paradox of
choice
well the paradox of choice is when we
have so much that we cannot make a
decision that happens to me every day
for example when I try to watch Netflix
that is I start looking for something to
look for and there's so much stuff that
I end up spending more time looking for
things to watch than actually watching
this stuff this has happened a number of
times and the only solution is to think
beforehand before hopping on Netflix but
the problem still stands and it still
stands for a number of things language
learning included I still remember that
some 25 years ago when I started
learning German I just found a course OD
Agostini teach the disco birthday and
that's what I used for one year and a
half before moving on to another
resource so I beg you if you have just
started learning a language or if you
want to start learning a language make
sure that you're going to choose one and
only one resource and use it in order to
build a very solid foundation in your
target language ok now that you know
that you have to use just one resource
how do you go about choosing that one
resource well I think there are three
main features to factor in when it comes
to choosing a good language learning
material first your language learning
material has to be comprehensible what
does it mean that a language learning
resource is comprehensible
well it's comprehensible when its
content allows you to understand what
you're reading and what you're listening
to
so only one hand the content should
contain obviously the target language
but possibly it could also contain
another version the same version in your
native language or in a language you
speak well so that you can use that
language you can leverage that knowledge
in order to understand and dissect your
target language but the resource doesn't
necessarily have to be just bilingual it
could be monolingual but if that is the
case
it has to be extremely clear and it has
to explain things so that you can
understand it in that target language
and third there could be a resource that
has content mainly in your target
language but also a vocab section in
your own native language or some
explanation in your own native language
of its grammar features the second
factor is that that language resource
should be enjoyable if it's an app
whether it's an app a book or a website
you should like its content visually you
should like spending time looking at
that resource in terms of visual content
and on the other side you should like
spending time listening to the audio of
that resource clear slow audio is very
important at the very beginning and
third that resource that you're using
should be useful that is the content
should be aimed at the skill you want to
develop so for example if that language
learning resource had real everyday
dialogues in your target language that's
great if you want to speak that language
well and apply it to everyday life
instead of say having very long
descriptive texts of the geography of
the country where your target language
is spoken or history or other things
that you can actually do and you can
learn a little bit later down the line
imagine a hammer with December you can
kill someone or you can build something
you can kill or you can create no matter
the quality of the hammer it's what you
ultimately do with it that makes a
difference a language running a material
is a little bit like that hammer most
language learning materials are
relatively good in terms of content but
ultimately the real good language
learners know how to use these resources
nowadays most language learning
resources are actually already pretty
good but what really makes a difference
is how a learner uses them now get this
the education system all around the
world over the last 200 years has been
hinging on the acquisition of knowledge
instead and to the detriment of learning
a skill this endemic form of poor
training applies to a lot of fields
ranging from mathematics to physics and
obviously to language learning have you
ever wondered why after majoring in say
Spanish for five years you have realized
that you can't actually string a
sentence together in that language even
if you know a lot of words come to think
of it language learning is a combination
of two very important skills the
capacity of acquiring knowledge on the
one hand that is words and grammar rules
and the capacity of putting these words
together and that is forming correct
sentences in terms of grammar and
pronunciation now kids do that very well
look at a five-year-old kid they can
already form perfectly grammatical
sentences in their own language but if
you ask them what is an adverb what is
an adjective
they have no clue because they have
learned that at school after learning to
put together sentences adults to have
these two systems in place but they only
use one system and that is how we
acquire knowledge adults also have
exactly the same capacity that kids do
how do kids learn languages so well
without even knowing of
Remer well they combine knowledge a
little bit of knowledge they know 500 to
1000 words a relatively short a
relatively small amount of vocab but
they immediately train in forming
sentences in combining these words
together to form meaning and Alice do
not do that in formal education we
mostly focus on acquiring knowledge we
spend more time speaking about the
language speaking about it features of
Strabo patterns its pronunciation
patterns then actually speak in it so
whatever resource you're going to use
make sure that you don't read it as if
you were a normal book use it as a
manual to build skills just to give you
an example instead of making lists of
words and trying to memorize them make
sure that immediately you take these
words in pairs or in groups of three and
you combine them in order to create
short and meaningful sentences until the
age of 14 I had been shamed to this
educational system and I thought that
the best way to learn German was
actually to try to memorize lists of
words and learn its grammar patterns but
after struggling a few weeks with very
very boring grammar exercises I realized
that I could actually do something else
so I started using a translation method
translating from German into my native
language Italian and back a few days
later in order to understand the
patterns of that language that worked so
well that I used that to learn German
and after one year I started learning
Spanish and then I applied it to pretty
much every other language that I speak
right now so to wrap up the content of
the video first make sure that you spend
some time doing some proper research to
find the one resource to start with and
use that one resource for a few months
before moving onto another resource
second make sure that this resource is
comprehensible enjoyable and useful that
is aimed at developing the skill you
want to
develop from the very beginning and
third make sure that you learn how to
use that resource to build skills and
sub-skills within the realm of language
learning you should not leave through
that resource you should not just read
or listen to that resource you should do
things that are aimed at developing
skills putting words together learning
to up their entire sentences and
ultimately to speak the language so
there you have it if you want to know
more please click on the link in the
description box there's a deluge of
additional information about this
fantastic topic thank you very much and
I'll see you very soon here on YouTube
[Music]
you
[Music]
you